Three
two
one
in this world we all write our own
stories we create our own destinies
are you ready I've been ready let's do it
everything is more connected than you think
it will be difficult and dangerous
this is personal
show them who we are. If you're proud of who you are it's a superpower
burns good or burnds bad...
it burned good
I'm in
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie Marvel
just released a new secret Invasion trailer with a
bunch of new footage in Easter eggs so we'll break
it all down a big part of roady's skull storyline
during this will also help set up the Iron Man
armor Wars movie so I'll explain what's going
on with that and I know there's a bunch of other
questions about what's going on with Ke Huy Quan
and Michelle Yeoh during this too because both
of them are big MCU actors in Loki season 2 in
shangshi too if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes I will
be doing full episode videos for secret Invasion
when it starts in a couple weeks we don't have
to wait that long finally this also set up a bunch
of other stuff that's separate from the whole Kang
storyline this is more earth-based stuff that it's
setting up during Marvel Phase 5 in the dark rain
era of the general movies that are happening the
next couple of years but one of the biggest new
scenes here is of Emilia Clarke's Gia character
entering this chamber that the evil skrulls are
the bad faction of skrulls were building in all
the previous trailers in this abandoned Russian
nuclear power plant they're using the power plant
to power their device here she activates it and
power surrounds her with energy and it looks like
a classic Marvel power upgrade type of scene like
a big glow up power upgrade for her the energy
in the device just evolving her skrulls Powers
turning her into a super skrull like some of the
other younger generation of skrulls during this
one of the big things that's happening like
you see some of them use their super skrull
powers like this is gravic the leader of the
evil faction of skrulls supposedly the younger
generation like this evil faction is trying to
turn themselves into Super schools like give
themselves even more powers that the older
generation of skrulls like the good skrulls
talos's group doesn't have making them a little
more like the skrulls that invaded Earth during
the original comic book secret Invasion able to
actually mimic the powers of the Avengers the
X-Men and their villains Amelia Clarke is playing
Gia talos's daughter she's like the little girl
from the Captain Marvel movie that's just grown
up now and the whole idea is they're just really
pissed off that Nick Fury hasn't helped them
find a permanent place to settle and call their
own there'll be lots of comments about this too
because even if Nick Fury has been broken since
the events of Avengers endgame seemed like he's
just been hiding out on his space station because
he doesn't know what to do and he hasn't assembled
the new Avengers yet it still feels like he had
all that like all the time during the 90s and
the early 2000s before the events of the first
Avengers movie to just find a different planet
somewhere in the universe for the skrulls to live
so during a lot of the previous trailers you hear
Emilia Clarke's character telling him you created
this problem this is your fault do you feel
responsible for all this because essentially
Nick Fury promised them a new home and never
delivered on it and so these younger generation
of skrulls is like fine we'll just take the Earth
for ourselves then and it seems like a big part of
that plot is giving themselves more powers like
turning themselves into Super skrulls one of the
reported things too there's been a lot of rumors
about Amelia Clarke's character turning into like
a version of comic book Abigail brand reportedly
some of these new powers that she gains is the
ability to create green fire or green energy kind
of like Abigail Brands X-Men powers in the comics
and I think part of the idea during this like you
see her cradling her father talos's body as he's
attacked here I don't know if he's gonna die but I
think part of the idea is that she'll become Nick
Fury's new right-hand person on this saber space
station in sort of like a version of MCU Abigail
brand but she'll just be using that name as an
alias there's been a lot of fan art of her as
Abigail brand obviously she wouldn't look exactly
like this when she's working with Nick mirror in
the future but you kind of get the idea you get
the vibe of the character like the idea is that
she would become a much bigger character in the
future of the MCU the same way that Kit Harington
Another Game of Thrones alumni as the Black Knight
will become a bigger character in the future of
the MCU it'll be real funny to actually see them
have a scene together during Secret Wars or some
future Marvel production like wow you look
familiar have I seen you before have you ever
tried to kill me everybody just waiting to hear
the Black Knight say that he doesn't want whatever
Gia Emilia Clarke's character is trying to give
him one of the big differences from the comics
though they have this whole plot here where the
skrulls are trying to give themselves more Powers
evolve themselves into Super skrulls during the
comic book Invasion the skrulls that invaded had
the ability to mimic the powers of all of Earth's
Heroes and normally skrulls don't have that
ability like normal skrulls only have the Cosmetic
ability to change their form mimicking Powers is
like Way Way Beyond that which is why the original
Super skrull was just one character like it was a
very special thing originally the super skrull was
meant to be one character and his name was K'lrt
forces I have been appointed by Emperor amok to be
your new leader he started out as a normal skrull
soldier in their army decorated for his bravery
his combat ability he won all these accolades
then fell into disgrace got banished then to tie
things more to secret Invasion the original idea
for the skrulls to pull off secret invasion came
from Emperor Dorrek who was the emperor before
princess faraki the person who actually pulled
it off came along bringing it back around to the
Fantastic Four because super skrull came from the
Fantastic Four Comics basically originally Emperor
Doric is the one who tried to invade Earth in the
Fantastic Four Comics it was way back in Fantastic
Four number two in 1961. like that's how far back
it goes the Fantastic Four wind up stopping the
invasion and then he basically takes all their
powers and grafts them onto colored making him a
skrull that has actual special powers whereas most
of the skrulls at the time only had the ability to
change form and just had basic super strength as
part of their biology their bodies are a little
bit stronger more resilient than human bodies in
the way that all regular asgardians who don't have
special powers just have stronger bodies and
live longer same thing with Loki's character
now like Loki and Thor are different because they
do have actual special powers like Loki practices
magic Thor has actual Celestial God Powers they're
just changing this a little bit in the MCU version
giving all these newer skrulls like the younger
generation special powers more evolved bodies
getting to the Iron Man armor Wars of it all the
way this sort of connects to the armor Wars movie
is that Rhodey during the series is reportedly
going to be a scroll like there's lots of rumors
and it sounds like in the last trailer he says
very skrull like things like you better be ready
talk talk they might find out what happened to the
real Roadie years ago I believe the idea is that
this version of roadie that might wind up being a
skrull if that's true has been a skrull for years
and skrull Rhodey has been using his access
to the present like during the events of the
series when things pick up Rhodey is supposed
to be the Secretary of State sort of taking
Thunderbolt Ross's previous job and he's become
the right-hand man to the US president and the
skrull has been using the access to the present
to help destabilize the world basically I think
part of graphic and the evil skrulls plan taking
over the Earth was to have humans essentially
destroy themselves like create nuclear assured
destruction and as part of that skrull Rhodey's
actions allow all of Iron Man's Tech to get into
the hands of villains all over the world as well
as Val and Thunderbolt Ross Who start misusing
it and during the Iron Man armor War series the
real Roadie returns to deal with that and take it
out of the hands of the government like the comic
book armor Awards Series so don't be surprised if
damage control winds up being one of the villains
during the armor War Series in fact during the
original comic book armor Wars the US government
actually uses some stolen Stark Tech to create
their own armor suit Iron Monger style like a real
big one called Firepower which Iron Man winds up
having to destroy so you can see how Thunderbolt
Ross and Val eventually lead to a lot of this bad
stuff happening during armor wars in the same way
that sword kind of became backdoor villains during
the one division series or at least people within
those organizations they kind of got into this
during the Miss Marvel series damage control was
using the Stark Tech drones the Edith drones
they just repainted them to look a little bit
different but they were meant to be the same
drones going after regular citizens instead of
just regular criminals basically the idea is that
during Marvel Phase 5 Thunderbolt Ross eventually
becomes president of the United States valo is
now in charge of the CIA and they're using it
to turn the United States into something more
akin to a police state in paying off that line
from Avengers Age of Ultron where Iron Man said
I would like to wrap that world in a suit of
armor the whole idea is that Iron Man had become
paranoid and he wanted to over protect the world
at the cost of everyone's personal freedoms in our
Thunderbolt Ross and Val are just actually doing
that so they do bring Justin Hammer back during
the armor War series they can just say that he's
actually working for Thunderbolt Ross and Val and
things start to go crazy with the armors going
out of control Ultron being released again they
don't actually have a release date for the armor
Wars movie right now so that'll probably wind up
being a Marvel Phase 6 movie there'll be a few
smaller delays just because of the strike that's
happening right now but those will be smaller than
the super delays in chaos caused by the virus that
basically wound up delaying pretty much all movies
and TV shows from every studio for about two
years talking about Ke Huy Quan and Michelle
Yeoh's characters in the MCU Ke is playing one
of the brand new characters during Loki season
2 called Ouroboros and he's the main Tech Guy of
the TVA who's been working there forever basically
but they just didn't go there during the events
of Loki season 1 so that's why we didn't see
him Michelle Yeoh's character will just continue
in Xiang Shi too when they get ready to release
that movie they don't have a release date for that
movie yet but that'll probably also wind up being
a Marvel Phase 6 movie as well if you have any of
the big questions about what's happening during
secret Invasion or the related series or movies
just write them in the comments below there's a
bunch of big videos that I'm working on right now
there have been some cool reports about Avengers 6
Secret Wars that support some of my theories about
the Legacy Marvel actors coming back again like
Tobey Maguire Andrew Garfield Spider-Man the other
Legacy X-Men actors I'll try to finish all those
videos as quickly as possible everyone click here
for my new Iron Man armor Awards teaser video and
click here to learn about how Robert Downey Jr of
all people almost became Doctor Doom of the Marvel
movies thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!